yo blackhead podcast episode 15 man
with the legendary hit boy my guy what's
good bro
um hit we've been talking off to mike a
lot but uh congratulations on
on everything thank you bro just locked
in man you already know
man i just been i've been seeing a lot
of love a lot of people add me on
ig add me on twitter just like man you
you're going crazy and it's like i feel
like i've been in this pocket but i
guess it'll just take a
minute for everything to catch up yeah
it's interesting because
obviously you and sean have been working
on detroit 2 for a long time
since 2018. yeah i feel like you know
this has been highly anticipated
house how long ago did you and nas
decide to fully
connect for king's disease it's crazy
because
like like you said we was working on
sean for a minute
we was already in a groove with that so
i was just you know from talking to him
every day working on his records and
listening to records that wasn't mine
but that he was going to put on the
album because i'm executive producing it
i just got so deep in a bag that by the
time me and nas length was
was it was only february of this year
that was six years six months ago i mean
it's [ __ ] in september right before
the pandemic right before the pandemic
that's what's crazy about king's disease
people think it's like
oh they they took the cove and [ __ ] but
we we could throw the king's disease
before
this [ __ ] cracked off before he was all
in the house before all the corona all
that
so um yeah we we connected in february
and
just did a record and we just kept doing
songs and
before we looked up we had an album and
it didn't even take long to get the base
of it like maybe a
couple weeks max wow um i want to dive
into
everything that's going on in the last
year but i kind of want to also touch
base on
you know a lot of people who are
watching this might not know you're come
up might not know where you're from
you're from
you're from fontana right
baby i'm from between pasadena and i.e
so i stayed all over the ie but
i stayed in pasadena until i was 13.
okay you know what i'm saying so
i just call myself a 210 baby i'm back
and forth off the 210 man
that's i take that i take that freeway
every time i go back home to phoenix
take the 210. but yeah so um
you started getting into music was it
first as a producer was it first as a
rapper like how was your introduction
into the into
just just creating man um
i was always into it but when i was like
13 i just like
picked up a pen and a pad and i was just
like man i don't know what
i'm about to say but i'm about to just
try to get something out and i just
every day i was on it just writing i
used to fill up notebooks just like you
know
rapping all type of whatever just
anything i could think of and then i
finally got to the point where i could
record
so that's when i met this kid in rialto
um this [ __ ] was making beats recording
himself
acid pro fl
bro so we was making albums and he was
doing all the beats and then
after a while i just started messing
with it playing i was just playing
around like and i just like this [ __ ]
pretty fun so i just kept going in and i
thought wow
like i was heavy on you know video games
and [ __ ] yeah i
i i replaced you know video games with
beats and i just kept making beats every
day i
i was playing basketball i played my
whole ninth grade years and uh
i was we was practicing for you know my
smile the this the next season
and bro over a weekend i like got a
computer
set up the fl and i went to school the
next week and i was like yo i'm not
i'm not coming back to practice bro i'm
about to be on these beats and this is
2003 so they looking at me like
get the [ __ ] out yeah beats yeah they're
saying like that's a one
early you get a one it's a one in a
million chance you're going that's like
early free loops was that that's around
the time
knight had probably made like like
little brothers started to pop
man that [ __ ] was like fl 3.5 like it
was just
i can't even remember the
functionalities but i don't think you
could do a whole lot back then so you
pretty much replaced
all of your extracurricular [ __ ] video
games
sports sports i'm going all in on beats
on just music i was making albums i was
recording i was writing i was making
beats just but
i'm glad i stuck to like the sonics of
it early in my career just like
because i feel like you get a longer
life when you locked in on the sonics of
it like
being a rapper you get a certain shelf
life so you know what i'm saying
everybody don't last forever with that
but
making beats you could catch runs on
runs like i'm on my [ __ ]
damn their third run i'm 33 years old so
it's like
you know um locking in on the sonics
also allowed me to be able to [ __ ]
make still make my music and make this
[ __ ] harder than it's ever been like i
feel like every song i do is just
getting better and better so
and i'm seeing people that i respect
reach out like yo you
you really going on this [ __ ] like it's
not just a beat so
it's just music at the end of the day
it's crazy because like you said you've
had
some runs right like i think we all know
your first kind of run
or introduction to everybody kind of
knowing that
who hit boy is was watch the throne
yeah that era of working with yay and
and um
in paris is one of the most iconic songs
yeah yeah yeah you already ever
like that that wave had to be like
it it you know from there you you you
you was on
you know working with riri and and there
was
rocky a crazy
run um i felt like
at that time i was real close with my
dude lifted who did mercy
who was working with kanye what what um
shout out to the homie
yeah but what um because why didn't we
get more music with you and yay
man bro look this is the thing and
that's that's why it's another like it's
another
part that's you know my story that's
disconnected because you gotta think
about it bro
i was assigned to good music for two
years right
as a producer as a producer and
i mean i produced you know wish you
would with him and jose i produce
steroid flu
um i produce click i produce
christmas in harlem i produce [ __ ] in
paris is that
mortal kombat on let's turn that thing
off
keep going but so so in paris click i
mean you know what i'm saying
it's just like that's just a two-year
span and let alone like you know
producing stuff like my god for pusher
producing multiple songs on john legends
i'm producing songs on big sean's
detroit one i had
i had a beat on there so just like i was
doing i did a lot of [ __ ]
you did do a lot i just think that like
once that two-year span was up
it it was it was almost like that was
like it with y'all
working together i mean you know we both
creatives
you know what i'm saying we both just
like it was always something
but it's nothing but respect on my side
you know as far as the creative goals
like when you were signed with good was
it like do they get first right refusal
on your beats
man i mean they would just take the
hardest [ __ ] so it was
basically like that anyway right i mean
you know it's funny bro at a point
i was like telling my manager like if
it's not yay
jay or beyonce like don't book no
sessions like this was that
for i don't know i can't think about how
long i was on this way but i was on that
way for a while just like
you know that's something that's crazy
to be able to even say
but you know i guess this is why when
people want to call it a resurgence now
like it's just me spreading my sound out
more and just locking in with more
people and just
dial in dialing in on just that level i
guess
now the other wave that i was a really
good
big fan of and really close to um shout
out to my dog's audio push
when you launch hs 87 um
and really just went hard putting on
your
your area no that was another thing man
like you got to understand i
[ __ ] i caught [ __ ] in paris and i
wasn't trying to make [ __ ] in paris
that was just the type of music me and
the homies did like one of my one of my
[ __ ] chilly chill
he had a you know he had a song on the
[ __ ] in paris b he was about to drop
that on his mixtape right
right before don c hit me like yo send
me the files like
that was just a beat that i was like
whatever on you know what i'm saying so
it's like um
um like you know balancing that
balancing producing for high level
artists
trying to do my own [ __ ] trying to like
you know produce for audio push
k roosevelt all the homies like that was
just a lot for a [ __ ]
25 year old to deal with and not having
like the proper infrastructure so
it just was me pushing myself every day
and after a while you just get burnt out
so you know
i just had to really scale back and just
get let me like let me just go back to
being hit boy like no expectations no
industry ass [ __ ] like i'm about to just
make heat and i'm finna lock
in is there anything you regret about um
that that hs87 era you guys made some
amazing music i think a lot of it was
really slept on i think
you know come as you are about audio
push one of my favorite tapes um
and i just felt like you guys kind of
despite even being um affiliated with
interscope at the time i felt like they
never really gave you all like
the to just do for the level of music
y'all were making was there anything
it's just like i said man i had so much
going on trying to you know
remain hot as a producer you know get my
artist hot all that [ __ ] but um
it ain't nothing i regret at all hell no
like you know what i'm saying being able
to put on for the homies get him
opportunity
regardless you know what i'm saying how
everything panned out
everybody's still doing their thing like
you're sure so it's like
we all got to learn i got to learn on a
high level you know i'm saying i
caught that record jimmy iveen just gave
me a crazy bag and
then the house but then that was it you
know i'm saying it wasn't like this is
how you do it
here's your front-end bag now you figure
it out yeah exactly so you know that's
that's that's cool but you know that's
that was like going to like college like
for me yeah you guys had a house in an
encino there
and tarzan tarzana yeah that was
cracking it was crazy
everybody was in rooms working like five
studios
everybody was pulling up working but you
know it also got to be too much you know
what i'm saying
at that i'm not yeah the parties were
kind of cool you know for sure
the parties parties cracking for sure
but just um
yeah bro like that's what led me to this
point i'm at now you know just
i did that for years like having these
home studios and just locking in and
having people in and out and i feel like
me going crazy now was me like i'm about
to go work by myself i'm about to like
just
really go back to just hit boy and uh
you know i got
i found a perfect room to lock in on
within the first year i want to grab me
out that [ __ ] with net rest of
people
in the middle so you know it's just oh
no i just went back to being
me like full-blown we also skipped over
surf club that area
right exactly surf club man surf club hs
87
[ __ ] all that that's that's that's
that's you as long as i'm alive that
[ __ ] is alive though
i'm rapping like that [ __ ] ain't never
going nowhere like it's just
you know it's time for everything 100
man um
all right so let's let's fast forward
now you know obviously
you're having an incredible 2020
i think that um i've seen a lot of
people eat [ __ ] during this quarantine
and a lot of people thrive and i feel
like
you are thriving my brother like yeah
man i'm blessed for sure
man and this is all [ __ ] that's been in
the works like you said it's not like
you know
like you made a conscious effort to like
ah that that go for like you know what i
said earlier in the conversation imagine
if i was just
just a rapper like i couldn't do no
shows right now like i'll be
on a different [ __ ] a lot of people
depending on those backhand
club bags for show so me being a
producer [ __ ] [ __ ] are still getting
beats through email and they still
pulling up doing safe sessions and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying as
safe as we can be and just you know
[ __ ]
being a producer is the [ __ ] right now
for sure let me ask you this
with king's disease are you uh were you
conscious of the fact that
people have critiqued nas for having
a bad ear for beats not for sure but i
mean
[ __ ] that's just people always form
narratives that
that [ __ ] listen now's my favorite
rapper ever yeah
that's just you know that's just people
talking just saying what they're gonna
say but at the end of the day
knives they wrapped on some hard ass oh
of course no matter
i mean no but i do think that i do think
that there was like an error in nazi's
career where he was like
definitely like maybe giving chris
webber a couple of beats on his album
that's funny i mean you know that's
where he was at in life but at the end
of the day man like i just knew it was a
job of service like that and i had to
really you know
i was putting on for a lot of people and
i know a lot of people
wanted to hear him sound good so dawg
for real
like i feel like it's almost like you
had a duty as like a
participant in hip-hop culture to be
like yo knives we gonna make sure this
[ __ ] is
solid i was on it every day man like we
you know i'm saying chopping on the
phone every morning like he giving his
thoughts on giving my thoughts like i'm
updating songs by the day adding
production taking away [ __ ] just trying
to make it sound
you know saying as enjoyable as possible
and for it to end up being you know
received on this level and you know i
woke up to a [ __ ]
facetime from timbala in the morning the
album dropped and
just the stuff he was saying i'm like yo
damn this is really like
it's touching people on that level you
know i'm saying you you always hope that
it will but
you want people on that level to reach
out and just be like yo this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] is super hard bro like and like
that's that's the win
obviously you and i was working together
at what point in time and and whose
decision was it to be like yo let's
let's do this whole [ __ ] together like
let's do a whole it was pretty fast bro
like once we because he could have been
like i just tried that
yeah yeah for sure i mean energy
the energy was just right bro like we
was making we was you
you hear the album like them joints a
lot of them joints like the skeletons at
least was being made within the first
few sessions blue bins you know what i'm
saying [ __ ]
car 85 like 35 so i'm saying before
charlie was even on it
it's just like you know we all we was
tapping in and we felt like yo this is
this [ __ ] feel different and he just
kept saying like yo i'ma just keep
pulling up
and he kept pulling up [ __ ] it's crazy
because
nas has always uh people have always
wanted to hear him
do full projects with producers
specifically prima
for sure primo is like the one that
everyone's like yeah well we need that
nasa primo album i remember there on the
cover of that scratch magazine back in
the day
yeah yeah and like you got it
like you got the whole nozzle like
project and it came out incredible man
like thank you bro
yeah now you and sean's relationship
obviously you guys have been working
like you said you were on the first
detroit um
you've been working with good music for
so long and
it seems almost like like i said y'all
been like you said you've been working
on
on detroit too since 2018. yeah it just
feels like
he really trusts you man and that's
you know it's funny because i've we've
had conversations about me obviously
making the album you're gonna go through
ups and downs and i'm like [ __ ] you
gotta trust me [ __ ] you got every like
really going in on that fact then you
know he like [ __ ] you got damn near my
whole album like i trust you you know
what i'm saying so it's like
um i don't know we just developed like
we always was cool
like i said we did click together back
in the day did a joint on detroit uh the
first detroit and
when we tapped back in it was at the
same time when i tap back in with nick
we met we we all linked up like i seen
them walking together
[ __ ] chopped it with them told him
like i got [ __ ] for both of y'all
uh sean pulled up we might have did like
six
seven just scratch ideas the first day
he pulled up and i'm like oh yeah
this [ __ ] felt right we got to keep it
going and we just kept locking in
yeah because i also feel like there's a
lot of pressure on sean man like
you know he tried putting out some
singles that that
you know i feel like the right approach
was to just drop the album and let the
people choose but you know def jam's
gonna try to throw singles out there
like he put out the berserk record which
was fire
that [ __ ] went gold but i'm saying that
[ __ ] was fired but i'm saying like you
know how these labels are like oh this
is not working on radio or
you know like for sure he's single again
was [ __ ] fire that's gotta be
that has like [ __ ] that [ __ ] is huge
but
it you know i feel like with sean like
kind of a similar space where it's like
yo you can't name something detroit too
yeah and it's because people fans at
least
kind of look at that as his best project
no for sure you know what i'm saying
and so for him to name that detroit
who's conscious of that for sure
and it also seemed like it might have
got to him a little
i mean like the pressure a little you
know artistry is a crazy thing man like
it really can [ __ ] with your head and
your emotions so you know
but i mean he he you could you could
hear in the album like
you're trying to personally talk about
growth you're talking about you know the
mental things that
bro all the [ __ ] he's been through and
it's like that's something that we
we should appreciate man because a lot
of people are not laying that all out
there like that a lot of people are not
being transparent in their music like
that
um deep reverence that record
was obviously sean's verse was recorded
after nipsey passed
um was that was that nipsy verse
gonna be for sean originally or was it
how did that work out
we was just cooking you know what i'm
saying like
the same time we had dead racks in the
middle he pulled up
um we did the first verse and he was
like man pull something else up
start start going through beats pulled
up the deep reverence beat
loaded it up he sat there thought it out
did the verse and um
again he was like [ __ ] let's go to some
other [ __ ] so we just was flipping
through ideas and
that was one that just was so happening
to me sitting there on one day
being uh sean was just having a real
life conversation about a lot of the
stuff that he talked about in
in deep reverence and um i was like bro
you got to put this [ __ ]
in a song in the song so i pulled up the
nip joint i was like this could be the
perfect [ __ ] for you to just spazz on
and
he went in was it hard like because you
know there's the interview clip at the
end where he talks about one to work
with sean
was it how hard was it to get you know
his fam
to clear to clear the verse was it i
mean they showed love for show black sam
like steve or stevo like the whole squad
they just
made sure it was a1 it wasn't you know
too tough i mean me and nip got a grammy
together so it's like that shit's crazy
you know what i'm saying that i'm i'm
taking care of the music for sure
yeah racks in the middle is uh all-time
amazing record getting that grammy bro
had to be like a
bittersweet thing you know what i'm
saying winning that but not having it
there to have it with you
nah yeah that [ __ ] was um it was dope
getting the grammy
but yeah i mean a lot of people ask me
like what which one mean more out of
like [ __ ] in paris and racks in the
middle it's just like
you know they both mean a lot but racks
that [ __ ] just was like
unreal bro like just seeing that whole
play all the way through and it actually
play out it's no
it was no industry [ __ ] to making a
record it wasn't no
and our ass [ __ ] like i put the record
together nip was [ __ ] with it he
you know it was his whole thing was like
i don't care who
not [ __ ] with this [ __ ] i'm making
sure it come out like his label was like
fighting him like yo it's another record
by another artist coming out you need to
hold off and whoopty whoop and he was
like man [ __ ] that he was like i went
and banged on them [ __ ] and
make them put it out so it's like for us
to win a grammy and then the other
record not even be mentioned it's like
okay i guess i do know something you
know no it was funny because i remember
when nip put the record out like we
i was talking to him and he was just
like i was like yo so like
was this like on the album and he's like
nah just it just feels like we like it
just felt
like we need to put this out like and
just see what it does because
one of them records definitely man it
was it was it was all time and man
oh god it just was a line it was
supposed to happen yeah and also a
record that really helped
you know obviously rowdy was was doing
his thing but really kind of helped kick
off
roddy's you know commercial looks
um when we talk about
your run benny the butcher was here
burden of proof you and him
crazy uh you're you're uh
just love with griselda has been lit
you're on um conway's album the record
you just put out with dave shout out to
um
um but yeah you and benny i remember i
was so excited to see y'all in like last
year i hit you i was like well i gotta
pull up here with y'all cooking
like because because grisel is some of
my favorite [ __ ] and i and you're one of
my favorite producers and
and i think it's like a a match
that i i knew was going to be fire but
it
seems like you know wait griselda and
hit boy i mean is this sound
like that that was with the knives [ __ ]
too you know people was like man i don't
know what this about to sound like
so for me to um always have this
versatile like
mentality and just versatile sound and
for people to think i only did club
records that this was a perfect
opportunity
for me to dial in with artists who have
that crowd that's going to be able to
show like damn like it really is that
you know what i'm saying on all levels
like you could do it out like i feel
like any you know
anybody can chase what's hot in the club
right now but to make those timeless
album cuts
sometimes records um what would like
again i'm sure it was like you and benny
probably chopping it up and then he
comes through and then it's like oh we
should just do a whole project
i mean how did that y'all saw him come
to l.a um we had never even chopped it i
just hit him like bruh if you uh
if you got time while you're out here
just pull up i got some [ __ ]
he came through first record we did i'm
like this [ __ ] a classic
hit up said first song so i'm like we
got to keep going
once again you kept pulling up before
you knew it we had an album done like
it's really been simple math like
just having that [ __ ] on deck having
some soulful having something hard like
just having different sounds and people
they gravitating towards
you know i'm saying without without it
being some watered down [ __ ] what do you
think it is about
uh the griselda [ __ ] benny conway that
the chemistry between you guys is so
natural
being somebody who's traditionally
looked at us somebody who's out at you
know cali you know what i'm saying and
those guys are so
extremely yeah underground east coast
boom bap [ __ ] i mean i just [ __ ] with
music period bro
you know what i'm saying like whether
it's some on the radio whether it's
something i'm hearing
out on a random like i just [ __ ] with
anything that feel like something and
feel
you know feel like they're doing it with
intention like you know saying every bar
them boys is
serious about this [ __ ] you know saying
you could tell and people who take the
craft series
when you when they link up you know
you're gonna get some beautiful nine
times out of ten so
i'm taking my [ __ ] serious the whole
gazelle today on they wave so
you know we locked in um i know you just
put out
uh you put out two two of your projects
you put out something with with dom
um in august it's also known as and then
you put out the chauncey house project
project before that yep um are you
obviously i just told you i'm like yo
man these projects are [ __ ] fire
bro um are you
by the way that record you got with
thirds where y'all going back and forth
it's crazy the mood change good
shout out crazy man and jan sport jay
um are you thinking about
doing a hit boy album that is
essentially
maybe you participating in rapping
somewhere but kind of like a
almost like some compilation [ __ ] where
he's some chronic [ __ ] i mean some
chronic [ __ ]
yeah i'm just i'm just working bro i'll
really be
that's the thing even with these
projects i'm putting together like they
so organic and it's just like once i get
in the room and
it's moving like we start to form it
naturally so i can't call what's next
but i just know like i'm cooking up
records every day i'm making beats i'm
recording
i'm doing all the above so it's gonna
line up eventually
who um is is there how about this
what's the other rapper that you have
the most records in the cut with
right now man i got a gang of [ __ ] with
sean i got a gang of [ __ ] with uh it's
my my [ __ ] t
grizzly he's you and t grizzly been
great serious man bruh
his last album you had some [ __ ] on that
that's his best that's his best body of
work he's like he's got five joints on
there
you know i'm saying we got an album
worth the [ __ ] though probably like two
items worth the music so
you know i just be taking it one day at
a time and trying to run it up with
[ __ ] as much as i can but
t sean um benny you know like i said
i'm just locked in uh obviously me and
don
got a honey record you went down that's
that's family that goes without saying
talk about you and don's relationship
i feel like dom has been i feel like
he's almost made the decision to like
i i don't know man i feel like dom just
be staying out the way
that's dom though you know what i'm
saying he one of the most cali [ __ ]
on earth you know what i'm saying so he
just
he'd be vibing just like on his own wave
like he don't care about
no extras like he don't care about no
industry [ __ ] he don't care about none
of that so
you know um when we linked
i mean we did music way back like from
the west side with love the first one
and all that
so um
for us to link like we linked like 2016
before we put out the first half a mil
and we just like was on a similar wave
like as far as
how we thought you know what i'm saying
like and that led into the music that's
why people hear our shin be like damn
y'all mesh well i wouldn't think but
like we think
similar to like as far as like just
being laid back not really giving a [ __ ]
about the extra 100
and [ __ ] so you know once we start
locking in this half a mil [ __ ] that put
me in perspective like
okay like this is how you make a project
that
you know feel like uh just like a moment
like something that people could [ __ ]
with and that's something i always
admired about his own [ __ ] like when he
put out an album it feel like
from the artwork to the merch he doing
like the music it just feel
real dom kennedy you know what i'm
saying so from me to locking with all
these other artists now like i'm i'm
just taking
a lot of the stuff from you know doing
the half meal albums and applying it to
what i'm doing now
give me um what's like your top two or
three studio sessions ever
just just obviously you know i'm sure
racks in the middle has got to be up
there but like in general like you've
had
some insane situation i mean you just
said i told my manager if it ain't jay
kanye or beyonce like i mean obviously
racks
making racks in the middle that whole
process was just fire from the time we
started it till we got it mixed and put
it out like
that [ __ ] was just a moment but um going
back like
when i first met hove that [ __ ] was
crazy what what session was that for
that was a watch the throne session and
i had been
you know we was working out at the hotel
in new york mercer hotel yep yep yep so
i had been up there a few days and i'm
like damn it's all going to come through
i'm just [ __ ] with kanye every day we
making beats together he recording all
my [ __ ] we just cooking
we was working on john legend stuff we
were just literally just cooking
a few days into me being there mind you
it's like a
snow storm and [ __ ] cold as hell so i
walked out
to like walk down the block mind you i'm
freezing to get down there
as soon as i get there i get an email
from yeah like yo you gotta come back to
the studio
so like [ __ ] walk back to the um to
the spot
and i walk in and hove is just you know
what i'm saying sitting right there
and he was just cool as hell like you
know saying i thought i thought
like i had heard like you know saying
like bro was like oh some like
mean type [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so for um him to be so cool that [ __ ]
was just flying man like damn like
you know and then we made [ __ ] in
paris it's just like you can't even
[ __ ] write that
that's crazy hey how many records uh
nev that we never heard because there
was this um rumored
sequel to the uh good music album that
was supposed to come out i heard one
song
called trash bags that lifted played me
uh
that was like almost like a mercy part
too but i'm sure there was something i
feel like i do remember that trash bag
yeah it happened it had the whole lineup
they had pushed they had everybody on it
i remember pushing pusha t had a line it
was like body bags i need my money in
body but it was crazy but nonetheless
um how many records did you guys like
did you have that were supposed to come
out that ended up not everything
that's the thing bro even with the whole
watch the throne [ __ ]
um we have made other records
in person like you know i'm saying like
[ __ ] in paris was a beat i just
emailed
the the records we was making while we
was in the studio was
uh totally different they didn't even
see the light of day they never
i thought them songs was going on watch
the throne like [ __ ] was hype on them
didn't make it and then this beat i just
randomly emailed ended up being like
damn that the biggest song on the album
so
oh no no no not damn near it's literally
the biggest song of the
world yo do you remember like the first
time you saw the
reaction in the club to that song hell
yeah for sure
because the reaction in the club to that
record was like obviously being
really on that i was just hype i would
be hyped to make a song and then go to
[ __ ] hide and
or wherever was cracking at the time and
just watching bro
that was one of them few records we had
them gravestone nights
you could bring that record back like
eight times back to back to back like
those happen like once every like 10
years bro yeah
like that record i remember you could
play that [ __ ] seven times in a row in
the club and that's a show in at the
concert
oh they did do it at the concert
actually that [ __ ] like 13 times i know
i saw them in vegas and they were i
think they did yeah
i think you were there in vegas too were
you at the video show uh
not for the throne show i was there for
a whole year in l.a though
i was in l.a yeah paris new york yeah yo
that shit's crazy man
yo look man quick break from the podcast
to tell you about odd socks all right
they're our official sponsor they
support what we do here at the bootleg
kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you got to do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks um i want to get
back to
detroit too i feel like
this album is is uh is is in the running
for album of the year
wow um it's uh
cohesively just incredible
you just mentioned that you and sean
have a lot of other [ __ ] what like how
hard was it picking the records
and forming the cohesiveness of what the
project ended up being
i mean that's the thing about being an
executive producer and then making
records yourself
it's like you know you don't want to
feel like you're just begging your [ __ ]
up
you know what i'm saying all the time
like so it's like i just try to
i try to just cheat on the line i'm
gonna let you know like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
hard to the [ __ ] like the
respective record like that was a
early in the process that was a record
that wasn't even really thought about
being on
um you know what i'm saying and then we
just started locking in on it more so
it's like
it's certain it's just certain moments
where you got to know how to
you know put put the bid in for your
[ __ ] but also you know
like okay this record by this person
also makes sense so
i just try to you know help as much as i
can but shawn knew what he wanted he
knew what
he wanted it to sound like so he really
placed everything where he needed to be
i just was kind of like you know his
extra ear
hey it came out it came out amazing was
it was it dope um
i feel like you kind of have a bucket
list of guys who've wrapped over your
beats
you just did a whole [ __ ] album with
nas eminem's on the friday night cypher
right and we did drop the world and you
did yeah i didn't even remember yeah
yeah dropped a shout out a little wayne
and [ __ ] that which i was that was a
rock album right
rebirth rebirth yeah that was the best
song on that album
[Music]
but um yeah it's crazy because like the
bucket list the artist that you've been
working with is like
like who's left you know what i'm saying
like that's right
as far as the all-time greats
whoever trying to lock in bro you know
i'm saying like
i ain't really you know
i can't call it man i'll just be letting
this [ __ ] flow and just let it happen
yeah i mean you know i wish outcast was
making music again because that would be
a movie oh you know what i do think
about that often i'm like yo if i got
you and andre if i got andre to my
studio
like well what could actually what are
they what are the possibilities that
could happen
uh uh honestly insane no clue but if he
came
bro you're gonna be over with yeah that
would be
that'd be special um you just tweeted
something uh the other day uh
was it yesterday about all the records
that you and travis have together
yeah and like what which was that which
which was everyone's favorite
you and travis uh i'm assuming there's
gonna be more music in the future
did you guys originally link up in the
good music days like back
back then because i know he was around
in that era
we linked before he even got wit or met
kanye like he was [ __ ] with
killhoffer kill off was mixing my first
song that ever dropped which was jay-z
interview
my first rap joint official rap joint
yeah you know
he came to my session and i was just
like um
we just chopped it it wasn't too much
but like when we finally
linked i just was like man this kid is
[ __ ]
he got it like i just saw the visuals i
saw the sounds he was using like
just the way he was approaching it i was
like he a real artist like he gonna be
straight in this [ __ ] for sure
and you know uh for him to take it to
this level man and it's like you know
we i mean bro you see that lineup
you know what i'm saying come on bro you
guys got classics bro
classics which part of sycamore did you
do i did the first part
before like before it cuts into travis's
part okay
i wasn't did you ever when you when you
i'm assuming you never heard saiha's
version of sickle mode
until everyone else heard it yeah i
don't think i have still even heard it
oh yeah did the travis party man scott
has a [ __ ] goat by the way shout out
to him
for sure man you know that's more good
music you and travis got any other any
i know he's working any are you are you
uh
you know hey man i'm just working bro
i ain't i can't put nothing out there
but
you know i [ __ ] with bro um i saw how
big of a deal it was for you to have
dr dre shout out
you know like that [ __ ] just took me
back bro like i'm like to listening to
[ __ ]
chronic when i'm 12 years old like still
living in pasadena
my family in the crib literally with
this [ __ ] on repeat
all day you know what i'm saying and for
him to you know saying
lock in on my [ __ ] and shout me out and
throw some bars on it you know what i'm
saying on the firm reunion by the way
come on dog that producer from cali
young producer looking up to dre popping
[ __ ]
you know that's just like movie [ __ ] how
um cause
did nas know he wanted to do a firm
reunion record like did he come to you
and say hey dude
i want to get everybody back together or
did the beat kind of speak to him in
that way
nah he had he uh we had to join he had
did his part
and um i just was like man we should get
a z on this [ __ ] and
as i told him once and he was like okay
for sure and then i
uh we played the song again i was like
yo let's get a z on this [ __ ]
and he was like you serious i'm like for
sure
sent it to him dude body that [ __ ] he
was like yo i'm about to just throw the
rest of the homies on there
and then after that he um he just i
guess he linked with dre just like on
some regular [ __ ] for them to chop it
and he ended up playing the joint and j
hop on that [ __ ] right there
yeah even to hear cormega on the song
with nas again it's so crazy because
they had like that
big falling out and cormega's so fire
yeah for sure
they all bodied it man foxy foxy of
course did was there ever any um
attempt to try to get nature on on the
record not that i know of
okay because i mean nature's the only
guy from the firm that was missing
or um shout out to nature um and then
dre
was probably the last piece i'm assuming
right now yeah he was he was the last
piece added
that's just crazy like now let's hit you
like yo dre
yeah he's on the [ __ ] what movie
fire that [ __ ] crazy bro kings disease
detroit two kings chauncey hollis
project is out
hey don kennedy also known as fire
courtesy squad man detroit two kings
disease right now
are you still uh technically roc nation
working with rock nationals
they helped me on the management side
okay yeah so on the management side but
like when you're dropping
like now when i drop my solo [ __ ] i just
dropped it independent just like you
know
going through the whole label [ __ ] like
i'm not trying to get involved in too
much of that i'm trying to really be
able to control as much of my [ __ ] as i
can
so whenever i feel like dropping i could
just drop and
that's what i've been on how important
has it been
you talked about being a chalice where
your studio is
how important has that location been to
everything that's going on right now
because
you said like people just pop in yeah no
it's been beautiful man shout out to the
whole
you know staff everybody they show love
um
being there i've been there two years
now bro and just like the amount of
placements and not even just placements
like helping people
you know put the album together and just
all the energy
nip coming through doing racks and doing
deep reverence and leaving that energy
in there like that [ __ ] is just
it's been love and then people also you
know rent the other rooms out there so
you know i run into people i lock in
with people that's just so happy to be
there that day
i saw you say that you would you you
said would you believe it if i told you
i sold
a million dollars worth of beats this
year a million dollars
worth of beats in 2020 come on man and
this is
i think you you might have said this
prior to king's disease from being out
i think i did yeah because i feel like
people are aren't like really hip to how
much work
like you got out there right that's not
that's not what's what's going on i mean
since i said that
damn there may be 20 songs didn't drop
that i produced so
like okay so how many when you say you
made a million dollars worth of beats
what like because because we think of
the old school days right where you
would hear like
we had scott storch in here and he said
that the most he ever got for a beat was
like quarter million dollars
yeah he was like but that was like the
peak no for sure i mean
the most i ever got for one b was like
75k
i ain't no no 250 [ __ ] but what do you
remember what beat it was
yeah it was it wasn't even like uh it
was like for a [ __ ] commercial no
storch said the same thing
he said that the beat was a commercial
he was like it was some commercial
and they paid me 250 and paid timberland
250 and we produced the song for a
commercial i said
what yeah so what's for what what come
what [ __ ]
gatorade [ __ ] damn a gatorade commercial
that [ __ ] is crazy
have you ever uh sold somebody a beat
and regretted it later
oh i used to when i you know cause
earlier
like that's why my volume is so crazy
now because i was trying to tap into
making like heartbeats down there every
time i sit down and you know now that
i'm
you know i'm just in that zone like um
back in the day it was just harder for
me to get [ __ ] off so
oh damn ask me the question one time you
cutting this out right
yeah yeah okay for sure yeah no but i
was i was saying have you ever sold
somebody
also or no that's what i'm saying like
that's what made me say that like
when i went out when i just you know
when i held on to every beating it meant
everything to me back in the day because
i didn't make as many dope ones
yeah so but now it's like man okay i'll
make another one like you know
that's just how i feel about it yeah
because uh i know
i asked scott i was like did you regret
giving hulk hogan's daughter
that's hilarious that [ __ ] is hilarious
um
one of the songs that i remember when
you first played me grinding
my whole life was at your house it was
probably six months before it came out
and i remember thinking to myself this
is the only song i've ever heard that
gave me
the same chills and vibes of of grinding
from the clips like it just was so hard
and like
that's crazy the whole [ __ ] crew was
on it my pops was on it
your dad was on it um
that song though the g-unit version
blew up you know see that's the thing
right and i'll be thinking about this
i'm like so
instead of just like taking a [ __ ]
style like
50 should have just been like hey boy
[ __ ] make an album for us or come
work with us
but it's like i think i feel like people
think too small you know what i'm saying
like [ __ ] like oh i see they having a
wave they got a heartbeat they got a
hard melody
idea vocal idea let me just take that
and try to wave up on [ __ ] versus
being a real one and being like i'm
gonna hit this [ __ ] and go make some
hard ass
i was gonna ask you like did did you
have any sort of cause that song was so
i know that was a very
important song for your label and for
your crew for my life
for your life all of that video was
crazy
like did you have any sort of uh
animosity towards the g unit version
i felt like people heard that b and
thought it was a g unit song
that weren't outside of i mean being
fans of what you were doing like
obviously you know what i'm saying like
at the end of the day bro
you know like i said man i feel like
they was thinking small by doing that
you know what i'm saying because it
didn't really even lead to nothing like
he just said the other day you want to
forget about g unit you know what i'm
saying and like i put my life on the
line to
make that record put my whole family you
know saying not my whole family but all
my homies and put my pops on it like
that was
that was that was that was real for us
you know what i'm saying like it wasn't
just like oh it's a heartbeat we just
gonna rap on this [ __ ]
you know i'm saying i feel like that's
what [ __ ] be thinking so it is what it
is
um you know for people who don't know
you
you said your dad's locked up again um
how's he doing everything i mean because
you know i always thought that was such
a beautiful thing that you had him on
we communicate we lock in you know what
i'm saying we talk
every other day and you know
it's just a unfortunate situation but
you know
once he back on the streets we right
back on this [ __ ] and then with the
with the other everybody else who was a
part of the crew k roosevelt by the way
k roosevelt is so fire that nigga's
fire fire fire yeah uh
audio push can't it's time to dawg it's
timing man but i'm just saying like
how's how is that i mean i you know i
talk to price and
and octane a lot but yeah how is
everybody is everybody still you know
kosher
he putting merch out putting music out
he's doing his thing
audio push stay locked in um
yeah all the homies kent money you know
that's my dog so he was on your project
mm-hmm yeah on chauncey hall this
project so
you know for sure um any chance
let me ask you this when you see like as
a producer
there's very like you'll see
people come and go a lot right i feel
like more
even maybe even more so than rappers i
don't know
there's been a lot of rappers have come
and gone in the last five years but
producers
i feel like it's like a year to two
years
right and then usually
they're sad because they have a such a
sound
that they're they're out of here right
it's like
that you know they got a cool
18-month run and then it's like well
what happened to those guys well now
there's the new producer you know what
i'm saying like
is that something that you're
self-conscious of and aware of
because you've never had a sound per se
that was like
like you said people would say to you
like ah hit boy you know i don't know if
i want to hear him with knives because
he's just making club [ __ ]
but like that's not the case if people
really have been paying attention what
you do
but like are you are you an observer
of the landscape of other producers and
kind of like
where people no you know i always
you know and i keep the game i'm a real
student in this [ __ ] i'll be watching as
much of it as i can and
i i never looked at it like it would
give me longevity if i stay versatile i
just looked at it as from a creative
process
you know perspective i just want to be
you know different every time like i
don't want to have a sound but i never
looked at it like
the sound burns out anyway you know what
i'm saying so i had moments of like
i would envy certain like you know
producers when it's like damn they
should connecting so hard but then i
might
have bigger records than them but it's
like it didn't connect as much because
it was no tag
you didn't hear that [ __ ] you didn't
hear certain people shouting me out
in interviews and bigging me up like
that so it just was a
more of a just real grind with my [ __ ]
it wasn't like a
autopilot type thing you know what i'm
saying like i feel like certain art you
know produce like you know like a
mustard like that [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] autopilot like you know what
you're gonna get you know what i'm
saying as far as like when he was on his
initial run when he was on his west
coast you knew he was funny
you knew what you were getting [ __ ]
yeah no mustard had to evolve
you know she had to and most people
don't for sure
yeah when mustard first came out it was
like like you said it was the 100 beats
per minute
it was you know you knew his sound and i
i got to give it up to muster because he
he definitely modernized it for sure
because he could have
burnt out so he could have man and he
he switched up and like [ __ ] the fact
he's got lma
and you know 10 summers he's doing it
man for sure
the producer tag thing i always wonder
this right because i'm like yo i almost
feel like
because you initially didn't have a tag
the crazy thing is on my first placement
on the jlo album i had a tag i whispered
hit boy in the beginning and then i
stopped using that [ __ ]
so you yeah but your bigger records
initially for sure
there was no tag on my first beat i sold
in oh
seven yes but then after that no tags
until [ __ ] damn there 2018 type [ __ ]
hey so
your first beat you ever sold was a jlo
record yeah did you meet j.lo i still
never met her to this day and this was
07.
damn yeah that's my first beat i saw
that [ __ ] is crazy so if you see this
holla at me man come say what up
now but i was going to ask you because
there's other producers that don't have
tags like
louis bell who does a lot of the post
malone stuff like what is like
do you feel like you kind of have to
have a tag nowadays because
no no you don't gotta have no tag but
it's just good for brandon you know i'm
saying i
was trying to get my brand up because i
felt i felt like my brand fell so far
behind because of [ __ ] like that and not
connecting it all the way so i'm like
let me just find an easy way to
just connect my [ __ ] now and it's
working out it is working out
or is it hip boy on the beat you got to
go dessert that's one of them
yo i'm looking all right so i'm looking
at the track listing with all the
producers right
cool andre's on here which is crazy no
id
mustard's got some on here um
these records that that
are you're co-producing with right
let's say like a record like uh by the
way the wolf song is crazy i don't think
he produced that [ __ ]
shout out day trip that [ __ ] is crazy um
but like
what is the being an executive producer
i don't think people understand what
that means anymore
yeah you know what i'm saying like i
said earlier in the conversation man
just having them you know difficult
conversations and
trying to you know just give my opinion
on as much as i can without being
biased or without being emotional about
it without being selfish about
you know how many songs i got on it i'm
just like i just want to give my opinion
to where this could be the best
possible you know project because sean
he was he was zoned in he was focused
you know what he wanted so i just was
like there trying to be a second ear and
add as much
you know as information as i could for
sure um
what do you see the rest of the year
looking like after after benny's a
butcher [ __ ]
man ain't no telling bro you know
telling i got more sessions lined up
you know some r b stuff some pop stuff
who do you want to work with bro whoever
want to work with me
[ __ ] and who really serious about making
music but i'm saying like who do you
want to work with like who are you a fan
of that you haven't worked with yet
man i can't call it i mean [ __ ] bro like
[ __ ] i want to do an
album for kendrick lamar you know saying
i want to do i'll move for [ __ ] jay-z
i want to do an album for plenty of
people but it's like you know i already
work with these people too but
if i can get an album with kendrick i'll
get an album with jay-z like you know
that'd be lovely
or even even yo i know kendrick was just
shooting a music video
i seen that i know you about you know he
about to melt the whole game
he bout to go on one of them them 12
month runs and then just disappear for
three more years
what about on some pop [ __ ] like i think
like i feel like you and post would make
some fire [ __ ] like oh for sure
like i said man whoever opened the work
really serious about music man
it's lit hit boy well honey boo let kev
you already know
go get uh everything this guy's working
on really disease detroit two aka
chauncey holly's project you already
know chauncey hollis project is [ __ ]
fire
thank you bro um i appreciate the fact
that you're
still on your rapping [ __ ] man yeah
cause you could wrap your ass off
and i feel like you're improving man i
am bro my every beat i do get better
every rap i do get better that's my
whole
you're the only i always tell this to
everybody because you'll be in the you
could go into any
studio session with a producer no matter
who the [ __ ] it is and they'll play be
playing beats
and there's going to be a few that
you're just like yeah i'm not feeling it
bro i've never been in a session with
you dog you ain't never played no wack
[ __ ]
ever no for sure it's all like
this look like ooh appreciate it this
[ __ ] is crazy
boom well look shout out to my guy hit
boy go support everything he's got going
on
they you got any sort of merch or
anything i ain't got no merch but i'm
locking in on it though i have something
so
gotta get that hit boy merch show y'all
cause y'all had the hs87 [ __ ] going up
yeah i was still mad i ain't never got
none of that
[ __ ] but it's all good we're gonna get
it back going
boom there you go man hit boy bootleg
cab it's lit 100 perfect